so i started a new game two hours ago
and this is my character i can get any
normal weapon i want to plus 12 at round
table hold at any time although this one
is plus 13 i have a shield that blocks
100 physical damage i have two
completely different sets of armor both
of which can get my poise upwards of 30.
i have this radagon saw seal which gives
plus five to four different stats though
i am level 33
my flask of wondrous physic gives me a
shield and increases the power of my
charged attacks i have two reliable
summons that have been levelled up to
plus two
i can coat my weapon in fire grease or
blood grease as much as i want because i
know exactly where to farm the materials
easily i have 10 healing flasks all of
which have been powered up by sacred
tears i can easily buy boiled prawns for
defense and i can easily make crystal
darts which are very useful in a variety
of situations i think i broke the game
let me show you how
first you want to visit the gateside
ruins located here here you get the
whetstone knife for ashes of war and
your mount with your mount head east to
this little encampment here you'll find
the armorer's cookbook one this gives
you the ability to craft fire grease
which we'll use later
after this head east along the path from
the gateside ruins until you come across
this bridge and this beetle this beetle
drops the ash of war determination which
is a powerful ash of war that can be
used on a variety of weapons from the
very beginning of the game continue past
the bridge and take a left here to go
north into the mistwood area
continue along the path avoid the giant
and head into the third church of
america
here you'll find your flask of wondrous
physic this is a customizable healing
potion that replenishes its one charge
at a site of lost grace make sure you
pick up your first sacred tier as well
these increase the amount of healing
that your flasks give you
next continue south along the path
soon you'll reach your first guide still
which unlocks the map for this area look
at your map and go towards the minor
earth tree here you'll find a basin with
two crystal tiers these can be added to
your flask of wondrous physic increasing
your stamina regeneration and the damage
done by your charge attacks which will
come in handy later continue south along
the path until you reach fort height
you'll find a grace underneath rocky
outcrop here make your way up to the
castle and loot your first golden seed
golden seeds increase the charges of
your crimson flask
now you can run past these enemies or
fight them it's up to you but as you
explore in and around fort height
remember fort height is where you get
blood items
first blood rose is a crafting material
that respawns every time you rest at a
grace blood rose can be used to make
blood grease which you can apply to your
weapon to make sure it does a lot more
bleeding damage the recipe for blood
grease can be found directly below where
i am now and the mini boss behind me
drops bloody slash which is an ash of
war that would be fantastic for you if
you're looking to do a blood build but
up this ladder is what we came for and
it's one half of the dectus medallion
we'll be using this item much later on
to shortcut into later sections of the
game
so if you don't have a plus three weapon
then you're going to want to visit the
limgrave tunnels located here what
you're looking for mostly are these
yellow deposits on the wall which are
smithing stones smithing stones upgrade
most of your normal weapons and that
number next to them in brackets dictates
what tier the smithing stone is in so
for example to get a weapon to plus 3
you need 12 smithing stone shards at
tier 1. the first upgrade requires two
the second requires four and the third
requires six so 12 in total then you
move on to tier 2 of smithing stones to
bring you to plus 6 and tier 3 for plus
9 and tier 4 for plus 12 and so on and
so on this white deposit is a somber
smithing stone used to upgrade special
weapons these work similarly to smithing
stones in the sense that they have tears
except you only need one zombie smithing
stone for each tier upgrade when you
think you have everything warp back to
gateside ruins and head northwest
through the ravine at the end of the
ravine is your second golden seed head
west from this golden seed until you go
through the grove of trees and the
graveyard in one of the graveyards are
the ashes of godric's soldiers next go
back to the golden tree and then head
east from the golden tree go through the
field of giants until you find this
statue get one to break it and pick up a
ton of smithing stone shards you now
have enough shards to upgrade your
weapon to plus three next go north until
you hit the war masters shack here you
can pick up a ton of ashes of war but
the best one might actually be no skill
which allows you to apply no skill to
your shield and allow your skill to
default to whatever your main hand
weapon is using this lets you use the
powerful weapon art of your main hand
without having to two-hand it when
you're done you can kill banal if you
really want his armor although that will
ruin his questline and i wouldn't
recommend it unless you know what you're
giving up the real reason we're here
though is right next to the warmaster's
shack root resin this is a core
component whenever you craft weapon
buffs you can farm this infinitely by
just resting at the grace and going to
pick it up if you want to make an
infinite amount of fire grease head
north until you find the other component
which are smoldering butterflies if you
want to make an infinite amount of blood
grease go back to fort height and run
around and inside of the castle to find
blood roses
[Music]
next we have to go south to the weeping
peninsula cross the bridge of sacrifice
and go through the ravine until you find
this upturned carriage inside is the
morning star a blunt weapon that also
does bleed damage both of which are very
important later in the run continue
along the path until you find the guide
still for the weeping peninsula unlock
the map and then continue along a little
bit further to this golden tree where
you'll find another golden seed
after this go back the way you came
except turn left near the ravine in
order to access the western side of the
weeping peninsula at the northern side
of the weeping peninsula you'll find a
sacred tier in the church of america and
then further along at the western side
of the island you'll also find another
sacred tier at another church of america
at this point it's time to do a little
bit of fighting so let's make our
character more powerful
walk all the way back to the church of
ella to upgrade your morning star to
plus three and coincidentally talk to
renner to get your spirit calling bell
also upgrade your flasks as well after
this we need to get an item that boosts
our rune acquisition for later in the
run
so go south west from the church of ella
until you hit the beach go along the
coast past the merchant and pick up the
gold pickled foul foot
these next two things are somewhat
optional although i would recommend them
if you want to be powerful head towards
the middle of the island from the
western side and you'll find the tombs
wood catacombs hidden under a little
precipice always loot all of the glove
wart inside of catacomb dungeons as it's
this upgrade material that allows you to
upgrade your spirits at the end of this
catacomb in particular you'll be able to
get godric soldiers to plus two and
we'll upgrade them a little bit later on
the end boss of this dungeon also drops
an incredibly powerful spirit summon
called luteal to summon him however you
need 21 points in your mind stat so if
you're planning on levelling a caster
build you might want to invest in luteil
and in your mind stat as well above the
tombs wood catacombs is an erd tree
avatar it drops components for your
flask of wondrous physic the opaline
bubble tear gives you a shield and the
crimson burst bubble tier gives you
health regen over time these two are
both my favorites so far in the game
[Music]
this is where things get real warped the
third church of america where you got
your flask of wondrous physic earlier
and go north behind the church at the
dead end of a river hidden in some
bushes is a portal this portal takes you
to the very northeastern edge of the map
in caled you are currently very
under-leveled for this area but that's
going to change very soon as we're about
to pick up over 50 000 runes in one go
we're going to head south from grails
dragon barrow as you travel along the
path you're going to see these guys
these guys are small but deadly they
will one shot you most of the time
however they're very easy to stun lock
and they drop a lot of runes so if you
ever need to quickly rune farm come here
walk to the froome great bridge which is
a little bit further on and kill those
guys for now though continue south past
the bridge and follow the path as it
curves to the right until you see the
putrid avatar go behind the tree of the
putrid avatar to find a spirit spring
which will bring you right behind an
enormous dragon we're gonna kill this
it's gonna take a while but it's worth
it
around this point you'll probably get
the invitation to go to round table hold
you don't have to say yes to this yet
and also while you're at the grace
checkpoint upgrade your crimson flasks
as much as you can
next we're going to kill the dragon i
want to mention at this point i'm not
100 sure that this doesn't ruin any
quest lines so if it does please leave a
comment and i'll pin that comment to the
top if this does ruin any quest lines
you can always go back to the little
guys at farum great bridge and farm your
runes there instead to kill the dragon
craft some blood grease apply it to your
weapon and get swinging we learned how
to do this earlier in the fort height
section however if you skip that you can
always just smack it with a normal
morning star since that does have some
bleed properties in a few minutes the
dragon will be almost dead and at this
point use the gold pickled foul foot in
order to boost your rune acquisition for
that big payout if you do this you'll
get 15 000 more runes because the dragon
drops fifty thousand and five of the
dragon hearts of its surrounding dragons
which die at the same time you can hand
in these dragon hearts for spells at the
churches of dragon communion located
here and here
make sure you spend these runes
immediately you don't want to lose them
so figure out what your build is
generally going to be because we're
about to die behind us is fort farah and
this is a tricky place to get out of and
defeat all the enemies within so we're
just going to run through it and
probably die at the end we're here for a
few things first you'll loot the other
half of the dectus medallion which we're
using later to skip to an end game
section but we're also here for
radagon's saw seal a talisman that you
can get by dropping down one of the
holes located at the end here when you
get down break through some pots and get
ready for a jump but make sure you loot
that item at the end don't do what i did
that item is a golden rune that'll give
you a ton of levels keep going and then
loot
saw seal
this gives you plus five in vigor
endurance strength and dexterity which
are stats that most classes end up using
and it all comes at the downside of
taking more damage now i tested this and
i only took a couple points more damage
than if i didn't wear it so that just
seems crazy good to me especially in the
early game where having 20 extra stat
points matters a lot more relative to
your low level
the next thing we have to do is travel
on this mountain path that takes you
around stormvale and allows you to
bypass it and go to the next open world
which is leonia of the lakes once here
go to the nearby church and pick up
another sacred tier head north from here
go through the ravine through the camp
and then sit down at the grace next to a
merchant this merchant sells the kite
shield which is a great 100
physical block shield and he also sells
the crafting recipe for crystal darts if
you don't have enough runes for these at
this point remember you can always go
back to faroon great bridge and farm a
little bit there but pick up the
cookbook and pick up the shield if you
don't already have a better shield we'll
use the crystal darts later on but for
now continue along the road pick up the
map fragment for this area and then
continue on until you meet this npc
sitting in this gazebo take this
opportunity to mark your map if you go
up you'll see a mining cave which are
these reddish holes right here
mark it because you've got a long way to
go as a side note that npc has a quest
that sends you to the northwest in
search of an abandoned hut find the
abandoned hut and the thug nearby will
sell you boiled prawns for 600 runes
each which vastly increases your
defenses while consumed so he's a great
source of defensive items and if you do
his questline he'll show up later in the
video in the next area as well after
this follow the path that is demarcated
by these light blue glowing lanterns
that appear within the fog every now and
then eventually you'll find your next
grace checkpoint and a guide still which
unlocks the middle section of the map
take this opportunity to mark this
gazebo on the map to your south east
this one gives you three smithing stone
shards tier three which will help you
upgrade your weapon very soon grab these
and head north to your main marker i
should probably explain what the main
marker is for this is for a cave a
mining cave that gives you a ton of
shards but most importantly it gives you
a smithing stone bell bearing bell
bearings can be handed into the statue
at the round table hold and from that
point on that statue will sell you more
items in this case the bell bearing will
unlock smithing stones tier 1 and
smithing stones tier 2 for infinite
purchase meaning you can get any normal
weapon you like up to plus six anytime
you want later on in the video we'll
unlock smithing stones tier three and
four for purchase which will allow you
to get any weapon to plus 12 which is
insane and i just think it's great to
give players this information because
i'm the kind of person who likes
experimenting with weapons and with
these unlocked you'll have way more
freedom to do so at the very end of the
video i'll talk about how to upgrade
weapons that require somber smithing
stones as well but for now explore this
cave and in this cave in addition to
smithing stone shards and somber stone
shards try to pick up a lot of cracked
crystals that you find on the walls as
well these can be used to craft crystal
darts and you got the recipe book for
that at the start of this area crystal
darts deal good damage they come out
quickly and it's good for finishing off
enemies it's good for minor enemies and
it's good for maintaining your super
armor damage that you've done to a boss
by dealing consistent damage and never
letting them recover
properly looted everything in this cave
you should have enough smithing stone
shard level threes in order to upgrade
your weapon to plus nine if you haven't
it'll probably just go up to plus eight
regardless upgrade your weapon as much
as you can by going to the blacksmith in
roundtable hold and by this point
rodericka should have also appeared in
roundtable hold talk to roderica then
talk to the blacksmith then talk to
roderiker again and back and forth until
she becomes a spirit tuner here she can
be used to upgrade your spirits and here
you should upgrade godric soldiers to
level 2. with your weapon and spirits
upgraded you should be ready to fight
the boss this is maybe the hardest thing
in the run although honestly it's not
that difficult the whole reason we chose
this weapon and the reason we chose
these spirits is because they all do
blunt damage to this boss and the boss
is very weak to blunt damage just let
your spirits get the aggro and try to r2
her enough to the point where she gets
knocked down
at this point her skin is cracked and
she'll get staggered and you can just
spam r2 to defeat her easily if you're
having trouble remember to use your
flask of wondrous physic and remember to
buff your weapon with fire as well now
you have the bell bearing and you can
get any weapon you like up to plus six
but what if you want to go further
[Music]
for this next section we're going to
unlock the next bell bearing which
allows you to buy smithing stones that
allow you to get your weapon to plus 12
which is pretty insane if you come back
here to clear the content with it at
this point i kind of want to offer a bit
of a disclaimer if you're not having
trouble with the game at this point i
don't think you really need to go much
further a plus six or a plus nine weapon
is more than enough at this stage and
you can just go back and level up and
clear the previous content if you do
want to go further you might risk
upsetting a few quest lines that you're
on and you're gonna see a lot of areas
that maybe should be saved for when
you're actually up to them but if you
really do want to become god mode early
then go for it you can use the dectus
medallions we gathered in previous
sections of the video to unlock the
grand lift for use which shortcuts you
into the next stage which is atlas
exit the lake here and head north then
north west until you reach the edge of
this cliff you'll see some graves
sticking out of the wall
carefully platform your way down and
then reach this grace checkpoint further
on from the grace checkpoint is another
sacred tier and further on from that to
the northeast is the grand lift
you can take a secret path to get up
here but honestly getting the medallions
was kind of on the way for us and there
were a lot of other great things around
those medallions so yeah this path is
great once you're at atlas plateau head
north east along the path to the left is
your first golden seed as well as a
guide style and a grace checkpoint
nearby directly west from here is
another golden seed and once you have
that one you can head east into the city
itself go up the hidden path to the left
to avoid getting shot by arrows and make
your way inside to find two golden seeds
and a grace checkpoint to the northeast
from this point is another two golden
seeds which brings your grand total of
flasks if you started with a golden seed
to
10 which is a staggering amount now if
you did the prawn quest line you can go
east from here and find the thug selling
more prawns for 600 runes each and these
are an even better version slightly
better but if you didn't do that go
southeast from the last golden tree we
visited and take this spirit spring down
into the lake we're heading to the cave
at the southern end which contains your
next bell bearing this bell bearing gets
your weapons up to plus 12 and it's not
even a boss fight you just find it in a
chest in this cave there's a lot of
illusory walls in this cave so make sure
you roll through them all to progress
and pick up as many shards as you can as
usual
so now with enough shards to get your
weapon to plus 12 or maybe even plus 13
you're very powerful but there's more
i'm not going to go as in depth on these
i'm mostly just going to mark them on
the map and help you find them for
yourself first if you want to upgrade
special weapons with somber smithing
shards then you can get the bell bearing
to upgrade them to plus 2 in limb grave
which has a transporter chest that takes
you there the path to the boss is quite
hidden and the boss is very hard you'll
actually have an easier time getting
your weapons to plus three and plus four
by accessing this cave here and getting
the next bell bearing from killing two
crystallines
now if you want the armor sets that i
mentioned earlier in the video you have
two options one of them is found in this
dark village to the south west of leonia
you don't have to go up to the plateau
it's actually underneath the plateau so
you just access it from the lake all you
have to do is talk to this pot guy and
go back to the round table hold and
you'll shortly have the armor the next
set is d'set which is a part of fear's
quest line to initiate this quest line
just talk to fear at this point in the
game and be embraced by her a couple of
times eventually she'll ask you to give
a dagger to its original owner who is d
so talk to d and progress that quest
line
if you're looking for another medallion
a great one is found at the very start
of the game behind this stoneswood fog
gate progress down avoid the chariot and
jump off the ledge here and progress
forward and you'll eventually find this
the erd tree's favor this increases your
hp your stamina and your equipment load
which is fantastic and also in the
description is a link to frenzy my new
piece of merch if you like this video
consider buying it it's only going to be
available for a few more weeks and then
it's never going to exist again so check
it out if you want to have something
else ring related to wear
also before i go i want to give a shout
out to r1 spam who helped me a lot with
some of the research in this video he
has a bunch of entertaining and
informative youtube videos on eldon ring
so please go and check him out but thank
you as always for watching i really hope
that this video helps some people who
are about to quit the game get a little
bit further and experience just the
majesty of this game like it's just
mind-bendingly incredible what they've
achieved here so enjoy and good luck